as you probably have been following Roy
Moore is an Alabama Republican Senate
candidate he's been accused of sexual
assault by multiple women including at
least one woman who was underage at the
time of the incident he dropped in the
polls precipitously last week the week
before and I said to you don't pay
attention to it doesn't matter that a
bunch of polls say that Doug Jones the
Democratic challenger is ahead I said do
not pay attention to it there have been
a number of factors that I have been
concerned would actually help Roy Moore
number one is the fact that a lot of
voters just forget about stuff after a
week and after we don't have the Roy
Moore sexual assault allegations in the
news for 24 hours a day or however many
hours a day it was a lot of voters would
forget about it they'd say wait I'm a
Republican of course I'm gonna vote for
Roy Moore the other issue is that some
of the allegations against others in the
last couple of weeks
Al Franken John Conyers even the non
politicians like Charlie Rose and Matt
Lauer I said it's going to help Roy
Moore and indeed it is happening Roy
Moore is surging in Alabama if you look
at recent polls there was this brief
period where Doug Jones was actually
tied or even ahead in a number of polls
and now we are basically back to Roy
Moore leading all recent polls by two
five and six recently in three recent
polls the Real Clear Politics average
right now has Roy Moore ahead by an
average of two percentage points
remember evangelical voters don't
actually care about Roy Moore being
accused of child sexual assault they
supposedly are mostly adherence to a
religion that dictates that they should
care about this but it's been abundantly
clear from the start that if you are Roy
Moore you just wait it out Donald Trump
waited it out more than a dozen accusers
including remember a girl who was 13
years old at the time that she says
Donald Trump raped her had accused
Donald Trump he waited it out he waited
out the grab and by the P tapes from
Access Hollywood he's president he's
President of the United States there was
no doubt that Roy Moore just had to wait
this out another interesting element is
that right
the first accusation against Roy Moore
went public Alabamans searching for is
it Alabamans or Alabamians Alabamians
okay I stand corrected Alabamians
started searching for Roy Moore a lot on
the internet as soon and the polling
numbers for Roy Moore went down as soon
as the week went by and the stories came
out of the news Alabamians stopped
searching for Roy Moore nearly as much
and his polling started going back up it
also probably is sort of helping Roy
Moore that Donald Trump kind of pseudo
endorsed him it was no big ringing in
door endorsement of Roy Moore but it was
the type of thing that it was kind of a
signal to Republicans that listen Donald
Trump says it's okay to vote for Roy
Moore and a lot of those Republicans are
going to and I believe that the bottom
line here is actually even more
disturbing it's not that for a while Roy
Moore lost support there was a period
where Roy Moore supporters were just not
admitting that they were still going to
support Roy Moore there is no way that
voters really switched in such
significant numbers away from Roy Moore
and then back to Roy Moore in a week or
ten days they were always for Roy Moore
some of them just lied about it when
they were being polled during the time
of the allegations often claiming that
they were undecided or that they weren't
sure if they were voting at all or maybe
even some of them saying they were they
were gonna vote for Doug Jones they
didn't really switch they just lied they
were always going to support Roy Moore
and remember what Roy Moore said after
these allegations broke that was just
the hit piece by the Washington PI oh
yeah yeah yeah post and it was you know
all done by the liberal mainstream media
to take him down it was the election if
it actually was wouldn't they wait you
know a week or two before the election
why would they do it six weeks before a
time to recover if if indeed it was a
fake story just meant as a hit piece
you'd want to do it that you'd want to
time it in a way that it would most
impact the election results not six
weeks before and there's kind of this
ironic thing where conservative southern
Republicans don't like how they're
perceived by US elite northeastern
liberals in cities
well maybe take a moral stand and don't
vote for the accused serial child sexual
assault er and
gain some more respect from the so
called northeastern liberal elites
this is tribalism taken to the extreme
if Hitler appeared and ran as a
Republican they would find some way to
say hey listen we don't want the
Democrat to be here because the
Democrats gonna do all this really bad
stuff and if Jesus Christ himself
materialized in front of us and said I'm
a progressive Democrat and I'm running
for Senate in Alabama you'd have these
same people saying that Jesus lost his
way and we're gonna vote for the
Republicans like that Trump supporter
who said that he'd have to check with
the president first right we're taking
Jesus aside if Jesus said what was it
something like if Jesus said there was
Trump Russia collusion yes the voter
would say hold on Jesus I'm gonna check
with Donald Trump first donate phone
Bank and knock on doors in Alabama okay
donate phone Bank and knock on doors
because as I said before those polls
could not be trusted and there's a good
chance that Roy Moore is going to win
this special election on December 12th
join us on our subreddit discuss this or
anything else david pakman.com slash re
d di t today's program is made possible
in part by Blue Sky binaries blockchain
Academy blockchain the technology on
which Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies can
be based many people not aware of both
the power and the risks that are carried
by blockchain technology I've only
started to get into this a little bit
buying a little bit of Bitcoin here and
their dollar cost averaging but a lot of
people myself included believe that
blockchain technology is just too
complicated to understand but the truth
is it doesn't have to be that way the
blue sky binary blockchain Academy from
leading financial education firm blue
sky binary explains how blockchain works
and it can work in addition to existing
knowledge that you have about blockchain
it's for both beginners and active
cryptocurrency users alike with the
course students are taken through a
series of topics which ultimately will
deliver a very solid understanding of
how blockchain works and help students
realize the potential future uses of
blockchain technology we've talked about
this in the pharmacy
we've talked about this in the IT
security world many many possibilities
for blockchain and the course includes
video on-demand online tests access to a
community of traders and blockchain
enthusiasts and at blue sky binary.com /
David you can register to get a free
three-day trial which includes access to
the first module of the course for you
to evaluate the overall quality and
decide if you want to stick with it get
a free three-day trial at blue sky
binary.com / David